live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show that is
dumb cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the ken coleman show
where he talks about your careers and
your jobs and anything we have to do
with making money is uh is my co-host
today as we're answering your questions
about your life and your money it is a
free call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five bra and andrea is with
us in new jersey hey andrea what's up
hi papa dave hi mr coleman how are you
guys doing today great how can we help
um so currently i'm a longshoreman and i
truly hate what i do i started it last
year before that i worked for an urgent
care hated that too
i think the only thing i really enjoyed
most is dealing with people with
disabilities it was a calling for me i
loved what i did except there wasn't any
money in that so i had to kind of move
along
um and
i just don't like what i do like i am a
people's person i'm not with people at
all i'm in a machine
like 42 feet in the air and i just don't
like it so i was wondering should i
search for a job that i love that pays
more or should i stay there to pay off
debt
a job that you love that pays more
correct yeah it's but it's both and you
don't have to choose so we would not get
a job that pays more that you love of
course you would do that
well the job that i work at now and pays
a lot i get paid a lot like 220 000 a
year
but it's long days i work from 6 in the
morning to 9 at night
uh
seven days a week
how much debt do you have
um about thirty five thousand twenty in
student loans six in credit cards seven
in medical bills what's your payoff date
if everything stays the same when are
you going to be out of debt
so i should have been out of debt by
next year however i got injured at work
at the end of march so i've been out on
workers comp and workers comp doesn't
pay a lot about 1400 every two weeks
when do you get back to our normal
schedule
uh hopefully by october it's the end of
september all right well so you're
you're posing the question of is of
should i stay where i am and pay off
debt or do something i love and make
really good money and it's it's it's not
a choice it's we want to get you out of
debt and while you're
looking for something that you love that
you can make really good money in that's
going to take some time that usually
doesn't just appear on a tree somewhere
so we stay put even though you don't
love the longshoreman work the fact of
the matter is you're making really good
money that's going to get you out of
debt faster get you into baby step three
quicker get that fully funded so there's
a timeline based on what you choose so
you got to get qualified maybe and then
you got to get connected you got to get
started and get moving into this new new
path so
stay put get out of debt keep working
the baby steps while we are exploring
and deciding and getting ready to make
that transition so that's the overview
here's the thing
your level of frustration
at work
will go down
dramatically the harder you work on your
exit
okay
if you just sit around and fume
and run the crane
you're just gonna fume
right
correct and but if you are
actively going okay i got i i've figured
it out there's 17 steps to get where i
want to go that's a pain in the butt but
i'm going to start working those 17
steps and i can do some of those from
this crane and i can do some of them
after i save up a hundred thousand
dollars after i get out of debt and quit
uh or whatever but at least developing a
plan the not knowing and the ambivalence
is much more stressful than even a hard
path
correct and so i think that's more so
what it is is that i don't know what i
want to do that's exactly what it is so
you aren't clear and so you're
frustrated so what we got to do is get
you clear i think the clues for you are
the work that you absolutely loved
before but now expand your ideas and a
vision beyond what it really was so you
loved working with people specifically
they had some was it physical or mental
disabilities is that what you mentioned
both
so why so getting to the why i'll just
put you on the spot really quick what
was so rewarding about serving that
particular people group
um it was just helping them they didn't
have a like
i was able to give them a voice that
they didn't have
um so it was
i don't know it was just helping like
helping oh you nailed it you just nailed
it that was beautiful don't forget that
i'm gonna give it to you one word okay
i think it's the advocacy side
you were sticking up for standing in the
gap for somebody a people group that
most people aren't standing up for and
that's what drew you to that work does
that sound about right
yes yes
okay now good so here's the deal so
that's a clue that we're gonna start
with so now we go up from there we go
all right that's the baseline i need to
be in a role where i'm advocating for
people who don't have a voice i want to
be the voice of the voiceless so how do
i make 200 000
and more eventually this is the
framework here so i've got to say okay
who uh who are the people that i want to
be the voice for let's start to get some
some some special groups that you go
okay well it's over here maybe it's the
mental disabilities physical
disabilities maybe it's somebody else
another people group that you feel drawn
to you go who's helping them now so we
start to go look into that world who's
serving that people group
nonprofits for-profit what's it look
like
products services
what is the whole universe like around
this type of advocacy work and now you
begin to see well there's this
professional path there's this one and
it goes on from there are you still
tracking with me andrea i am definitely
trusting so now you begin to see things
you haven't seen before and so then
you're going to sit down and talk with
people who are winning in that space
that are making really good money in the
product or service lane okay
and we find out what it looks like day
in and day out this is called clarify
and verify and then as we pick something
we okay now it's going to take this much
certification or some type of education
depending on what's required it's going
to take this level of experience
and so today's point you may be in that
crane for a while to save up to put
yourself in a position
to then go down
it won't seem like long it won't because
you because it's part of the plan then
rather than just a place to fume
okay so what happened let me just tell
you you're an advocate or a uh a
crusader
and um
[Music]
so 30 years ago a bunch of banks crapped
on me
and i spent the next 30 years pissing
them off
so i'm a crusader it's what i do i'm an
advocate that's what i do
for people that regular people that
never even stopped and thought that the
bank is screwing them
they're being thought that bank of
america and sofi are actually filthy
dirty words
they never even thought about it
and so we started putting that in their
brain and showing them how and so it
doesn't necessarily have to be something
as
uh in other words a crusader an advocate
isn't necessarily someone who simply
helps somebody in and out of a
wheelchair
it could be a much bigger
thing
than that single act a matter of fact it
should be i don't just sit and do
budgets one-on-one with people anymore
but that's where i started that's right
and so um we can take you there hang on
we're gonna give you a copy of ken's
book paycheck to purpose and also a copy
of the assessment to take to help you
get clear on where you're going but i
think we got a good head start on it hey
i'm proud of you you're a neat lady get
after it girl this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
have you ever found yourself saying one
day
one day i'll be able to buy a house one
day i'll be happy in my career one day i
won't have to battle with anxiety one
day i'll get my debt paid off hey listen
you're not gonna do anything when you
start saying that
that just that's kicking the can that's
all that is you gotta stop waiting
around
whatever your one day is you gotta start
that's why we created smart conference
it is oddly enough a one-day event where
we tackle all areas of your life and
help you get moving along let's get some
traction let's face it we could all use
that kind of a boost
and you hear from some of the nation's
top thought leaders and best-selling
authors on each of the subjects
career mental health
money relationships
marriage
leadership this event is hitting the
road and we'll be coming to dallas these
are my best speakers the best people i
know to bring i'll be sitting in the
audience and speaking when rachel cruz
my own daughter number one best-selling
author many times over will be speaking
dr john deloney number one best-selling
author speaking on
mental health and mental wellness ken
coleman sitting to my right right now
number one best-selling author will be
speaking on career our hottest new
ramsey personalities george campbell
christina ellis and the space of money
i'm going to be there speaking and my
friends craig and amy groschel pastors
at life church in oklahoma city one of
the largest churches in america will be
speaking on marriage so every subject is
covered by some of the best speakers
communicators thought leaders in these
spaces it's it's the kind of information
you need
and a whole day of it i mean you're
gonna it's like drinking from a fire
hose you know go up to a water fountain
to get a drink somebody turns on a fire
hose that's where you're gonna go home
emotionally tired from learning this
much in one day and it's only 39 for the
day because the vip and platinum are
already sold out the event is almost
sold out it's august 22 october
22nd almost had it over there october
22nd saturday all day long in dallas
texas go to ramseysolutions.com
slash events and get your event passes
immediately if not sooner this is the
thing to do get er done right now
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five elizabeth is in
birmingham hi elizabeth how are you
hi dave hi ken thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
well my husband and i actually filed for
chapter 13 bankruptcy
back in may
and guys this is the decision that we
are regretting right now um
at the time just long story short we
were in a bad financial place earlier
this year i had lost my job and so
we were working the baby steps we were
on baby step number two when all this
happened and
i think in a panic of realizing that we
were down to one income
we panicked and
did some stupid things and got into more
debt and then realized that hey
uh we got to pay this off how are we
going to do it we weren't looking at the
bigger picture and so we filed for
chapter 13.
and fast forward to today we're in a
much better place i have a great job my
husband's doing well
and guys we do well every month except
that pesky payment that we have
is really cutting into our monthly
income and we were we're in gazelle mode
right now we're selling everything that
we can sell we had a yard sale and we're
doing good and bringing in extra money
but in bankruptcy you can't you know you
get that payment and you got to stick
with it and we are actually we have an
appointment with our bankruptcy attorney
later this week to actually see about
just getting out of bankruptcy just
canceling it all together and
uh taking on the task ourselves and we
would love to get y'all's opinion on of
whether you think we should do this or
just keep at it with chapter 13. okay
uh well first let's establish a couple
of things
once the uh file has been opened on you
at the courthouse
that's where the phrase comes from
filing
bankruptcy and a number has been
assigned to you so you have filed
bankruptcy you cannot un-file bankruptcy
you can voluntarily dismiss a chapter 13
but if anyone ever asks the question
have you ever filed bankruptcy the
answer for the rest of your life is yes
okay me too by the way
yes
i filed chapter 7 in 1988.
so me too
been there done that uh and seven's a
lot worse than 13. so
uh but but that's really a misnomer
because right now what you're asking
about is the cash flow and what kind of
risk and stuff have you got so what kind
of debts do you have
our biggest one guys we have two car
payments and um that
our cars were we owe more on them than
they were worth at the time now since we
filed i don't really know the standing
we also had about 25 000 in credit card
debt and about 6 000 in personal loans
no student loans and that's all we have
at this time
okay and what do you owe on the two cars
uh the two cars right around uh probably
thirty thousand dollars each
okay and um
you think they're worth somewhere in
that vicinity
uh probably a little bit less um
probably around i think we could it may
be more just dependent on how the the
market is right now
uh but i would say dave probably around
26 or 27 000 at least
okay
all right
um
and and so what do you guys make now
what's your household income now uh our
household income per month net after
health insurance taxes and all that
we're looking right around 5100 a month
um and then the bankruptcy is running
what's your house payment
uh we rent and our payment is 1400 a
month
okay
all right so the way you can kind of
analyze this is uh pretend like you took
a
a baseball bat and you hit a hornet's
nest and you threw the hornet's nest in
a closet
and it closed the door
okay
you're getting ready to open the door
oh lord
all of these people
are not mildly pissed they're going to
come after you with everything they got
and you've got to have a plan for taking
care of every one of them if you're
going to open the door
okay so you need more information on the
cars can you get out of these cars
because you probably need to sell both
of them
uh yes sir we can we've actually got a
little bit of money from just the
gazelle intent of selling everything
stashed aside to where if we needed to
pay the difference we could and and then
you're going to get something to drive
for cash
yes sir well what was the 6 000 the 25
000 was credit card debt and the 6000
was what
uh personal loans
okay to who
let's see just lenders in general um
audio credit like personal lines
okay yes sir yes sir they're gonna be
the worst
versus credit cards
okay because they're basically bottom
feeders
they're going to come after you um
really really aggressively so you're
going to knock those out really really
fast
the credit card companies are
um
incompetent
inefficient
so the uh how aggressively they chase
you will take them time
during that time you need to just be on
the phone with one at a time of them and
get a payment plan going
okay if you just start paying them
payments most of the time you 99 time
you shut them up
okay okay okay but you you can't just
ignore them
because now they've got you've got no
protection because federal bankruptcy
filing puts a stay an injunction like
telling a dog stay
on all of the creditors they can't touch
you they're the hornets in the closet
with the door closed when you
voluntarily dismiss you open the door
and out come all the hornets so you need
you need you you need a bug spray you
need uh flyswatter you need uh a hood
that's you know on your head or whatever
it is whatever metaphor we want to do
here to keep all this crap from getting
at you right and so yeah go ahead and
dumping the cars uh and so forth all of
that'll work uh by the way inside the
chapter 13 you can probably get the
trustee's permission to do the car deals
okay and dump the car deals and get your
cars all situated
and you know pay the payment for one or
two more months all of the payments
you're paying is going towards your
debts anyway you're not losing any money
by paying payments because you're going
to be paying payments after you come out
of this
so you're still going to have payments
and there's still going to be a bunch of
them
you just want to make sure you got a
plan but i'm with you if you can step
out of that 13 you probably can manage
it
more efficiently than you can inside the
13 if you're willing to dump these cars
especially
wow
lesson learned
bankruptcy is not something you do
impulsively because i'm scared
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today
in phoenix arizona chris and andrea are
where this says on my screen you guys
are debt free congratulations
thank you yes we are we are officially
completely 100
never going back into debt-free i love
it i love it how much did you pay off
so we paid off the mortgage that took us
about 10 years as about 211 000 but all
together
from when we first picked up the total
money makeover in 2011 to now it's a 267
631 dollars i love it
and uh what was your range of income
during that 10-year period
we ranged between 150 and 250. cool what
do you all do for a living
well i
am a former tv news anchor here in
phoenix arizona and i left uh in 2018
but that was my career path for many
many years almost 15 years and i'm a
firefighter in phoenix okay very cool
very cool so andrea do i know you yes we
do of course we do
you know chris too in fact we were
we visited you as well in 2019 not that
long ago okay i thought that was you
guys all right well congratulations you
guys way to go you did it what's this
house worth
we just looked it up the other day it
was 670
000. how much in the retirement plans
uh just over eight hundred thousand ah
baby steps millionaires how old are you
two
so that was our thing as i we had this
goal in 2011 that we would be debt free
before andrea turned 40. she's a little
older than me
wow brave guy 40 so 39 and then she's
now 40.
all right and your baby steps
millionaires i love it yeah he is a
brave guy he runs into burning buildings
and he just called his wife old i know
yeah
i'm more wise actually
whoa
quick around there
way to go you two okay so tell us what
started your whole ramsay journey ten
years ago
so we were we were just normal we were
normal americans uh
student loan debt credit card debt car
debt
and it just seemed like no matter how
hard we tried we just kept falling
further and further behind and i
remember driving down the freeway to go
to the fire station and uh used to have
this in phoenix you had this billboard
that said act your wage and you were
cutting up a credit card
and i thought what does that mean so i
found your book and
we went through that that total money
makeover book and started teaching fpu
and it was just it like it changed our
lives it changed the way we looked at
money
and uh so that was kind of like think
the seed we planted and then we got on
the same page as well we started kind of
um you know looking at our future and
deciding how we wanted to look and how
we wanted to raise kids and what we
wanted to teach them
and um and then also started buying
stopped buying things that we uh
couldn't afford and justified it with
you know we deserved it we make good
money we work hard you know the whole
story that we all tell ourselves and how
we all end up getting into debt sure
but now with 1.4 million and you're not
even 40 you don't have to get up at 3
o'clock in the morning anymore no i
don't thank you jesus
i mean if it wasn't dave it wasn't for
finding you i mean obviously
your your plan your book your your
ministry that you you do for all of us
it's it wasn't refining you there's so
many things that happened along the way
that we could have never imagined like
when the kids got older and andrea's
thinking you know i get up at 2 45 in
the morning i never see them because we
had no debt and because we had a giant
emergency fund she was able to walk away
from her job it was it was little things
along the way that happened that we
didn't like our goal was always to be
deaf free but there were so many wins
along the way by just you know
not doing stupid things with money yeah
yeah for those of you listening or
watching a lot of folks don't realize if
you turn on your television at six in
the morning and someone is there and
bright and chipper and cheery it's
because they've been up since three
[Laughter]
2 30 is when i woke up
15 years of that monday through friday
and i we were just talking about this
the other day
i thought well actually we're talking
about last night we had a real late
flight getting in we were on a vacation
and i said i used to wake up at this
time what in the world how did i do that
for so long but you know you do what you
have to do for a while and now we're
well past that and uh you know life
looks better than i think we ever could
have imagined it
yeah you know i'm going to turn that
statement uh that question into a
question for you tell folks how do you
stay in it for 10 years to pay your
house off what kept you guys going
because now you're on the other side of
it
you know i there were there were so many
days that were hard i will say but we
were so we were such a team
and we could not have done this if
either of us were on a different page
and so i think we just kept that goal of
one day we'll you know have a paid off
house one day we won't be making
decisions um you know based on oh well
we have to do this job or i have to work
here because we have you know xyz
um to pay off and so we just
stayed so focused on that and some days
it was so hard you know people would
make fun of us and you know i we still
drive
old cars but they're nice cars they're
just old um and
you know now it's just such a way of
life like i could never imagine living
the way we used to live ever again amen
the freedom we feel today
nothing can take that away yeah yeah
way to go you guys i'm so proud of you
man what a wonderful real moment we've
i've been dreaming about this i've been
listening to your show for 10 years and
every time i have like i hear somebody
on the radio doing their debt free
scream i would send it to andrea and be
like hey this is going to be us and you
know x amount of years or whatever and
it's just it's just kind of sitting in
this moment right now i'm like i cannot
believe we're actually on or we're doing
our debt-free scream i just it's this
and surreal it's so surreal and i will
say i gotta just add this in here
because we have really sat in this the
last like month or so since you know
officially paying off the mortgage
and i told chris the other day i said
you know
god man he's so good i said his math
though it does not make sense to me
because what we paid off in the last
year you know our income has changed
significantly with me leaving work but
for some amazing reason like he's just
amazing because it doesn't add up what
we paid for the principal and how much
we were able to pay off in the last year
with having less of an income
um but man when you're faithful and you
just keep stewarding it the way we're
supposed to steward it and you stay so
focused on his way over your way like
everything changes for the better money
changes relationships change everything
gets better amen amen it's a different
economy than the standard math for sure
yes and it's a better economy my
goodness amen amen well so proud of you
too very very cool it's good to hear
from you too copy of baby steps
millionaires coming your way since you
are officially one
uh and a copy of a one-year subscription
or uh membership to financial peace
university i know you've already been
through it but these are things you can
give away and help somebody along the
way as you keep talking about having one
with this it's not bragging uh it is
testifying
there's a difference and so also copy
total money makeover for you to give
away to somebody so we're going to give
you lots of stuff there to help you out
and just to say we're proud of you
congratulations my friends very very
very well done chris and andrea phoenix
arizona 211 no 267 000 total paid off a
little over 10 years house and
everything baby steps millionaires
before they're 40. making 150 to 250
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream ready yeah three
two one we're dead
this is how it's done
man oh man oh man oh man
see uh ken you know this our our
listeners don't but you and i and the
other mg personalities we have the
pleasure of
being in studio with a lot of television
personalities on the national scale our
friends up at fox for instance and uh
lots of the cities that we go into will
be in phoenix in a few weeks and be
doing television there while we're there
and hanging out with people and getting
you know we because i've been going into
that studio off and on for 20 years i
end up making friends and uh you know
the uh honestly the funny thing is i
mean your cameraman your audio guy or a
gal the lady calling the shots and you
know calling the camera shots and the uh
anchor in front of you uh it's not
unusual at all for one of them to start
following the stuff we teach and then
they'll give you an update when when we
drop by there the next year or two hey
man i did it i've been working here for
two years i got out of debt and uh some
of these folks we've struck up
friendships with over the years and
chris and andrea are on that list i'm so
proud of you guys very very very well
done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
cindy's in baton rouge hi cindy how are
you
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um
we have my husband and i have 460 000 in
a money market type account and then we
have 135 000 in cash
and we're to the point of saying what do
we do with this we're not making any
profit on most of that money and um we
took the 460 out of equities and
securities because we were losing a lot
of money in that
and uh
that money had come from a home that we
sold and because we got an interest rate
of 2.5 on a new home
uh we went with the 2.5 and put the 460
into securities and equities and uh
didn't want to lose it
beyond what we put in there so we put it
in the money market
parker what do you owe in your home
366k
okay
um
from 30 years of coaching people how to
become wealthy
and from doing a study of 10 000
millionaires
these are the two sources for my data
that tells me the shortest distance
between where you are
and wealth
is two things as a um
consistently funded
401k roth ira in good growth stock
mutual funds over a long period of time
that becomes some money and a paid for
house our last debt free screen was a
six hundred thousand dollar uh paid for
house and eight hundred thousand dollars
in their 401k or reverse i forget which
but it was a 1.4 million dollar net
worth
and it was just a few moments ago while
you were on hold you heard it
yes okay so that is the typical path
that we see
that is the most often used by people
who become millionaires now where does
that take us in your situation it says i
would pay off my house today
because here's what you ended up doing
it wasn't the start of your plan
but the net result of your plan is you
borrowed money at 2.35 percent and
invested it at a half a percent
right there we were i know that wasn't
where you it wasn't what you set out to
do but that's where you ended up isn't
it
it is i pay off my house today
today
my close of business today write a check
okay
okay and now you don't have any house
payment anymore how's that feel
awesome because i want to retire yeah
and now you got 200 000 in cash that we
got to do something better than a stupid
money market account with you need an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses for your short-term emergencies
and um i mean you know let's call that
50 grand at your house for the fun of it
you've still got 150 000 that you need
to do something with other than a stupid
butt savings account now if you put it
into some kind of a mix with a stock
broker and you were losing money
i get that if you put it into good
mutual funds and the overall economy
slowed down like it is right now and the
value went down
then you didn't have somebody good in
your corner to coach you and say hey the
only person gets hurt on a roller
coaster is those that jump off in the
middle of the ride which is exactly what
you did
now were you invested in single stocks
no you're mutual funds
very diversified in mutual funds
some of them were in mutual funds okay
well what i would do is sit down with a
good investment broker and here's what
you're looking for this time
um
and uh you're looking for someone with
the heart of a teacher that teaches you
the history
of the mutual fund that you're putting
the money into
okay i'll give you an example i own one
that's over 80 years old in the 80 years
it's been open
fewer than 15 of the those 80 years has
have been a down year so if we happen to
have a down year and i know that
i know that not my broker knows that but
i know that then i'm not freaking out
it's kind of like the house that you own
in baton rouge if it went down in value
this year you wouldn't freak out because
generally speaking homes in the
neighborhood you live in for the past 40
years have gone up in value agreed
agreed so you wouldn't freak out on one
down year and bail out that's just like
that mutual fund i'm describing i'm not
going to freak out in one down year and
bail out but that's all knowledge on
your part rather than depending on
someone else to tell you what to do and
then you get scared because you watch
the news
and you never take financial advice from
the news
if the commercial breaks where you're
watching tv are walk-in bathtubs
gold commercials and reverse mortgages
and snuggies that tells you you don't
want to take financial advice there
that's just a bad plan
and so
uh here's me looking at you fox but
anyway yeah so there you go but the uh
fox business right but i love them
they're wonderful but the commercials
are comical saturday night live i'm
trying so hard i i can't hold it in
you're not saying walking bathtubs are a
bad idea it's just the investment advice
i'm just saying if this is where you get
your investments
in the commercial breaks or walk-in
bathtubs and snuggies then you know
you're not getting good this is this is
a bad place
oh that was perfect i'm sorry that just
got me that was like the church giggle i
couldn't hold it
we've all sat and watched them at the
commercial i know exactly i know exactly
what you're talking about
and
and we're on there giving financial
advice so what do we know but anyway the
uh uh
but you know you really need to sit with
a good broker who has the heart of a
teacher go to ramseysolutions.com
click on smart vester
sit down with them interview them
and what you're looking for here is a
type of wisdom
not intellect
there's a difference
there's a lot of very very intellectual
ignoramuses out there
and that's not in the world in in
general that's not what you're looking
for you're looking for common sense
wisdom that says i bought a mutual fund
that for 80 years has only had less than
15 down years so we're having a down
year i don't need to panic
and that you learn that you internalize
that you emotionally swallow that and
then it becomes part of your plan and so
in that situation then you invest in
good mutual funds in your 401ks and your
roth iras and those kinds of things and
you get your house paid for and that's
what i'm going to do with your 150
unless you've got other debts and then
we'll clean that up too
so i want you to debt free 100
and investing in good growth stock
mutual funds that is the shortest path
that have long track records that are
comfortable to you and that you
understand what's going on you didn't do
it because i said do it or because some
goob at a financial office said do it
it's because you learned and your
knowledge allows you to sleep at night
you know ken that's the difference
between tossing and turning at night
when the stock market's down yeah is
whether you made the decision based on
knowledge you had or knowledge someone
else had yeah well it's true i mean you
know for years i mean before i even
started working with you this idea the
roller coaster analogy that you've given
and it's really true when you look at
the data
if you look over the last 30 years you
just got to stay calm and ride this
thing out and i just don't freak out
when i see the stock market dip you know
i say hey we keep investing that's an
opportunity it's going to come back and
you're right knowledge uh is what gives
us tremendous confidence and confidence
the peace yeah and once you really
understand that folks about the stock
market then when it goes down you kind
of go like it's on sale yeah we're
getting bargaining right it's a bargain
time yep this is a time to buy well we
don't really do that either because i'm
not going to tell you to time the market
i'm just going to tell you steady invest
steady invest that's all i have done i
have been tempted at times when the
market is down to time it yeah i really
really wish
in 2008 when the stock market was
crashing and it was coming to an end and
it went from 13 000 to 6 500.
i really wish i had put an extra million
dollars in
yeah
because i mean the dow's sitting at what
six x of that that million wow today
would be worth six million wow because
it does you know thirty thousand over
thirty thousand right
so um yeah there you go i mean that's 5x
5x yeah to be worth 5 million dollars
now ultimately i did have money in there
and it's worth 5x but if you could have
timed the market and bought at the
lowest possible time we've seen in
decades
then that would have been the time to do
it but who knew when the bottom was
if i bought it 6 500 it would have gone
to 6 000.
well there's a chance yeah then i'd have
been pissed i missed the bottom not that
i was gonna lose money but because i
missed the bottom so don't try to time
the market people trying to try on the
market don't win they really don't and
jumping in and out based on what you
hear on the news
based on whether or not russia invades
ukraine
is really a bad idea
you gotta have a long term scope on this
stuff and ride it out and that includes
having your house paid off cindy so
thank you for calling we appreciate you
being in our audience this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is done cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the king coleman
show number one best-selling author is
my co-host today
and uh he of course specializes on your
career and your jobs and so taking your
calls about that subject as well today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five matt starts off
this hour in atlanta georgia hi matt
welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys so cool to be on i'll jump
right into it so
me and my wife are working the baby
steps with great success i've got a good
job i make
decent money
i've got some of the best reasons anyone
could ask for to get up and go to work
every morning but i still find myself
struggling
pretty frequently with
finding meaning
and fulfillment in my career i don't
think a shift in careers is the answer i
think i'm you know with the right
circumstances i could feel the same way
with any kind of job
so i would love your perspective and
your input on
recommendations on things that i could
do or book recommendations to help
kind of
pivot my perspective and start looking
for meaning in my every day so if i
heard you right you're looking for
meaning but you don't think you don't
think it's a move in uh professional
occupation is that what i heard
maybe one day but at this moment my
current career makes the most sense as a
vehicle to reach financial peace for for
me and my family okay well so that's a
little bit different focus then instead
of what you're doing um you need to be
focused on what you're producing so what
do you do
i do heating and air heating and air so
you're out there working on hvac systems
yep okay great so if based on what you
just said i want to challenge you in a
moment on the big picture but
if i'm looking for meaning
i'm going to be focusing on the relief
on men and women's faces when you show
up to fix the ac i mean i'm telling you
if you're showing up to fix ac in
atlanta in august uh and a lady answers
the door believe me you're more
important than her husband at that very
moment am i right
am i right well well
in in the rare scenario yes but these
last couple years what i've been
noticing is that smiling face is
becoming
much more scarce and the the frustrated
paint up just
the anger seems to be much more common
in in my personality i understand that
and i and i don't dispute that but my
point that i was making their little
humorous take is is that you've got to
focus on you are providing uh emotional
relief yes they're they're they're
they're upset at a lot of things in life
and certainly because their machine
isn't working or whatever but you are
providing emotional relief you are
providing uh comfort for for people to
sleep at night there's a lot going on
there and i think that's what you have
to focus in on and and you have to say
you know what right now
my job is to uh come and uh fix a
problem but more importantly do it in a
way where people do appreciate the
service that i've brought them even if
they're not super kind and super nice
about how they treat you
based on what you've told me that's what
you have to focus on is what's at the
other end of your work and at the other
end of your work is peace of mind and
comfort and let's be honest safety if
we're talking about heating in a very
cold you know environment so that's what
you're focusing on and then you're
grateful
for the job
uh and what it's doing for you and
paying off debt uh giving you stability
to do that so gratitude on one end for
the job and then uh appreciation for
what you are ultimately providing
yeah um
why i i mean
if you're on time
and your company's not over charging
there shouldn't be really any anger
corrected at you just frustration that
they're heating airs out
yeah it's not necessarily at me i think
it's just the the last couple years have
been a little wild and i think i'm
noticing that wear on people's nerves
more and more and unfortunately
sometimes i'm the target of that if that
makes sense just because i'm there and
they're already in a frustrating
situation
um if i could ask you what would be if i
catch myself in a moment and i'm just
frustrated and worn out or or whatever
and i'm struggling to
feel grateful what would be an exercise
you would
recommend i kind of put myself through
to to reset myself i guess yeah well you
got to go right back to hey um i've been
able to pay off this amount of debt uh
we're going to be out of the baby step 2
at this such and such a time
this is providing this for my family you
just you retreat back to what this job
is allowing you to be able to do and so
it's not really fancy it's just retreat
to clarity i'm clear on what i'm
grateful for and i know that this is
just the season that i'm in it's not a
sentence it's a season big difference
and i think that's all you can do in
those moments but i would really
challenge you i'm just curious let's
fast forward because i know you've
thought about it
what would you do long term if all this
debt was gone and the emergency fund was
fully stocked and you had options what
would you do
well that's
that's that's kind of a struggle
um
i would love to write a book that's my
that's my dream eventually um i just
don't have tons of time to to work on
that day to day right now that's fine
but but
where i find myself kind of
battling internally is i'm i think i'm
i'm
above average and pretty much anything
that i apply myself to but i have no
idea what i would actually be great at
does that make sense i don't know what
my
specific niche skills are i don't know i
hear it all the time i hear it all the
time and i'm going to give you my get
clear assessment which will help you
have some self-awareness and then get
feedback from people but when i
encounter someone who says that
that's a person who for some reason
has some self-doubt and i think the
people who know you best maybe maybe
you're one of your favorite coaches or
teachers uh or co-workers i'd be asking
the question and then your wife uh
family members who are gonna be honest
with you
you know what you're above average in
and just say am i above average you see
me that way and where you're above
average see that can be turned into
greatness so that's real talent that can
be honed think of talent as like a ball
of clay and when the potter puts uh the
pressure of his hands and the water on
it it's shaped into something
tremendously useful so that above
average that is what you're talented in
and then applying education applying
practice and experience to that talent
that can become a super skill so stop
wondering so much get some verification
confirmation from people who know you
well use the get clear assessment i'm
going to give you and it is in those
talents where you're going to see clues
to enjoyment to work that you enjoy
doing so hang on i want to give you not
just the get clear assessment which will
give you a great report on talent what
you do best passion what you love and
mission what motivates you see those
three things are vital for someone to
get clear and then make really really
good money and tremendous impact i'll
give you the book from paycheck to
purpose as well which is the map that'll
help you climb up the mountain once you
determine what is that long term that
dream that peak that you want to scale
and i on the short term i don't know how
much control you've got over the
situation but um
we're in a business where sometimes
people are stressed out too they're
freaked out they've got money problems
and sometimes they want to transfer
their frustration to one of our team
members
and we just tell them they're not
allowed to do that
um we're not here to be abused we're
here to help you
and it's not customer service to be
abused that's just lack of boundaries
and so if you got somebody's out of
control
you may need to deselect them as a
customer
like fire them as a customer
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two
five have you heard the news
we're in a recession
stock market's falling
inflation's out of control
it's pretty easy to get out of control
yourself isn't it
if you watch the news all day long it'll
put you in a rubber room man i mean
seriously
yes there's some real stuff out there
but this is not time to panic and if
you're investing it's definitely not
time to panic you got to stay
level-headed you don't jump off the
investing roller coaster in the middle
of the ride that's the only people get
hurt
so uh you got to watch out for the gloom
and doom
people they're out there
and history shows that the economy
recovers time and time and time again
so
you got to have somebody to guide you
through these times when you're
investing and that's why we have the
smart vester program
the smart investors smart visitor pros
don't work for us they're people that we
recommend that are in the financial
advice business and they help you with
your investments
with the heart of a teacher meaning
they're going to teach you what you're
getting into you're going to know what
you're getting into and you're going to
want to stay through downturns as a
matter of fact once you really
understand a downturn you're almost
going to be tempted to invest more at
downturns
ramsey solutions dot com slash smart
vester if you want someone on your team
to show you how and what is going on
ramsey solutions dot com slash
smart vester garrett is in las vegas hi
garrett welcome to the ramsay show
hi ken hi dave thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
hey so my question is
where do unexpected home repairs fall
into baby step two
emergencies
okay so let's say that the emergency
fund is it an emergency
um
i'd probably say it's not an emergency
then you don't do it in baby step two
got it so we wouldn't treat it
like a
an emergency if it's not
okay because
basically um
we it's a bathroom and our kitchen kind
of got shut down because of a leak
we gotta fix the leak um
well the leak is fixed but the insurance
didn't cover the cost of the total
repair so essentially we're just down
the bathroom now so it's just like
essentially they said it's going to be
seven thousand dollars to fix the rest
of the bathroom
i'm sorry stop stop stop stop stop the
toilet repair cost seven thousand
dollars
no the bathroom it's the whole bathroom
okay what's wrong with the bathroom
so um we had a
leak that went unnoticed um for about
six months uh murphy's law we bought our
house last year
and
we didn't notice it was coming from our
master bathroom into the kitchen and it
basically we noticed it when the floors
were potentially
starting to you know
cave in a little bit
and
obviously with mold remediation um
repair um pretty much the insurance only
covered to a certain amount so it
covered like the cost of the kitchen and
the demolition of the bathroom but
pretty much like
almost all the walls are like down in
the bathroom and then no shower
and pretty much the whole thing is you
know
gonna cost
seven thousand dollars so i didn't know
if we would save
something
no you will probably pay for that before
you need to move you got to classify
this need whether this is an emergency
or whether it isn't so i don't
understand why the insurance didn't
cover the entire repair
uh because
the limit on the um hidden water leak oh
only a ten thousand yeah i got you okay
that makes sense
all right so um
how many bathrooms do you have
uh well it's a three bed two bath and so
you have one bath operating
correct and you have how many people
two
you and your wife
yes
okay
and what's your household income
uh we met 110. and what's your debt that
you have remaining
uh 69 000.
okay it's going to take you two years
okay
to get out of debt right
yes
roughly i mean 18 months to two years if
you're really hardcore on this it
shouldn't take you longer than two years
um
okay um
the way i try to answer questions on the
show is what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes
okay what do you owe the 69 thousand
on uh well uh 31 000
roughly spread over
two cars
28 000 in credit card and about ten
thousand pay in student loans
and what is the most expensive car
the most expensive car
oh okay
so the most expensive car is gonna be
like my off-roading slash overlanded
vehicle
and that uh that's like 19 000.
okay
all right
um
would you trade that for a bathroom
absolutely
would
really
that's what we would
because i might not
okay anyway here's the way i answer
questions what would i do if i woke up
in your shoes you have a bathroom it's
just the two of you this is an adventure
let the stupid thing sit and get
yourself out of debt that's what sharon
and i would do if we woke up in your
shoes now if i wanted to get out of that
a little bit faster because the bathroom
um is a big deal the second bathroom
uh when we have one couple living in the
house um i mean i want you to get the
stupid thing fixed obviously but it's
you know if you want to speed it up the
way you speed it up is you start selling
off the expensive cars
and that speeds up how fast you get out
of that right
yes because one third of your debt or
one-fourth of your debt is one car
that's true and boom you know we just
cut down your two years to uh
you know a year and maybe 14 months or
something like that
and you can knock the rest of this out
if you want to now really what that buys
you is um almost a year of fighting this
stuff and waiting on to fix your seven
thousand dollar bath but no i would not
budget in a
non-emergency
non-leaking you do have indoor plumbing
you have a bath
um
sounds like a little creepy of a
situation but i'm with you our roof was
leaking when we were broke
and we decided we were going to live
this way
i got some of that black tar stuff in a
5 gallon bucket and smeared it around on
the roof and stopped the water from
running down the light fixture onto the
kitchen table
it looked like crap but i could not
afford a 6 000 roof at the time and
that's what it took to put a roof on
that house
and uh we lived like that for two years
while we got out of that and after we
got out of debt i put a new roof on the
house with cash because i don't borrow
money anymore and i wasn't going to stop
getting out of debt for that one place
that it was leaking and couldn't figure
it out a cheap way to do it so i just
made a mess yeah i completely agree a
couple one couple no kids one fully
functioning bathroom take care of your
priorities it's not that big of a deal
it's a great story to tell anyway you
know all your friends and family already
know about it anyway because of the
ordeal you've been through yeah
and you kind of you know
someday when you have kids you can go
you know back in art 22 we lived with
one bathroom
you know you tell the grandkids that
right what'd you call that stuff you put
on the roof what was that black what was
it tar
yeah
whatever you call it well no the reason
i said it because i recently had a i
recently had a leak in my roof which you
know about and i just didn't have time
to get anybody out there and so i waited
until it stopped raining i got that flex
seal from that awful infomercial that
guy screams at you about putting his
boat back together why didn't you just
throw your shamwow up there
so i went up with the flex seal sprayed
it stopped the leak until the roof was
getting out did it really well now we've
got an endorsement for flex seal i
didn't mean an unpaid endorsement i
didn't mean to do that unpaid
endorsement but i mean you know where
there's a will there's no i mean this
was you're in a different century than i
was when i did this i love that though
i love it 1988's a different world
22. can you even get tar for your house
i doubt it i don't even know how that
stuff works it's just that it's like
like dr it's well it's nasty yeah it's
nasty i love it it's a great pretty much
pretty much white trash that's what i
was doing
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
dhruv is with us in greenville south
carolina hey drew what's up
hey thanks for having me on
sure how can we help yeah
so i currently have
student loans so i just graduated
undergrad
in spring of 2021
and i went to a full-time job right
after about a week after
and then i started grad school
last august which is a two-year program
um so i've accumulated uh
pretty much a good bid in student loans
about
90 to 90 000 total by the end of my grad
school career
so i'm trying to figure out you know
what's the best way to attack that
amount as quickly as possible because my
goal is to
be financially free and debt-free as
quick as possible so
and then one more thing is my current
employer
found out they have a tuition assistance
program so
that's they're going to knock off about
30 grand right there so
really i'm looking about 60 000
so trying to figure out the best way to
you know pay that off as quickly as
possible
what do you make
uh
about 70 000 okay what's the uh what are
you
studying in grad school
um it's a masters of engineering
management
okay
and what's that costing
it's costing 60 grand
and you're how far into it
uh i finished one year so i have one
more year left
okay
what does that increase your income by
for having that um
i'm hoping you know
the company i'm at i'm not really sure
what the pace structure is for a
management role because currently i'm in
a technical role um
i would have to guess i mean about
minimum 90 to 100 starting as a manager
oh and you make what now
70. oh yeah okay
but you're guessing number one so go
find out
number two
uh you know if you're an engineer and
you busted on a technical level
am i incorrectly presuming that you'd
have an opportunity to move into
management or do you have to have a
master's degree to get into management
level of engineers
um
i don't i don't think it's necessary to
have one i think it it accelerates the
timeline um
it kind of pushes you a little bit
quicker up the top of the chain from
what i what i've heard from people at
the company okay
all right
uh well you're halfway there you're
gonna finish it so the way you get out
of student loan debt is you live on
nothing
and beans and rice rice and beans you
don't go inside a restaurant unless
you're working there's an extra job and
you don't go on vacation you live on
beans and rice rice and beans and you
attack the student loan debt as fast as
possible you got 60 000 to pay off while
making 70 towards 100. um so
you know you need to do that in a
maximum of two years 2500 a month
2500 a month and you start that now
because you're currently having 70.
and not take on the debt
yeah
um
well i also just bought a house too i
was renting about a uh early this year
but that was a huge mistake
really you're broken 90 000 in debt
yeah
okay
um
well i i i don't know my thought process
was i mean i'm starting to build equity
earlier um listen here's the thing okay
um you're going to have to
decide which thing you're going to do
and the thing you're going to do
if you believe the shortest distance to
becoming wealthy which we do and we have
data to actually prove it it's not a
theory
and we've been doing this for 30 years
the shortest distance is to
not add new debt
number one and then number two live on
nothing
and clear your debts as fast as you can
because then you will have control of
your most powerful wealth building tool
um
and quit using your own analysis
on these things because your own
analysis sucks
it's what got you where you are
so um don't don't look in the mirror
again and say to yourself you know i
kind of reasoned this through no because
your reasoning has caused you problems
it's got you into a mess
and so you don't need to use your
reasoning you need new sets of
information to make this decision if
you're an engineer you built a bridge
the bridge fell
we don't want to use your calculations
again
okay that's not a good it's not it
doesn't build a good bridge and so that
that's where you're setting
and um
so
you know
uh
now
thanks for calling we appreciate you
calling in now let's sidestep a second
ken because um
a 60
degree that might maybe
maybe increase your chances of
that's overpaying for a master's it is
and you're right he's halfway through so
we might as well finish it but the
approach the reason i asked that
question is i want people to think about
this unless it is the only way meaning
there is no ticket to the dance if you
don't have this higher ed degree then
you've got to think through it you take
a young man like this who's fresh out of
college he's got to earn it he's got to
pay his dues dave he's got to crush it
in the now
and then his he does a great job goes
above and beyond what his leaders ask of
him to do he shows himself to be humble
in the workplace he shows himself to be
hungry look for more opportunities to do
what whatever it is to win he's going to
have an opportunity for leadership
regardless of the master's degree take
the same person with a master's degree
and they have the supposed edge and
they're up against a guy who doesn't
have the master's degree and one is
humble and one is hungry and goes above
and beyond what's required of them
leadership will look at that person
unless there's some sort of weird goofy
politics involved and they're going to
promote that person every time well you
can pay 80 000 for an mba or you can pay
17 000 for an mba well there's that too
that's exactly so you need to think
about what you're paying and
um once again we just wanna underscore
for everyone out there not just that
young guy but for everyone that not all
education is worth what you pay for it
that's correct it does not give you an
roi a return on investment necessarily
and so if you pay 17 000 more for an mba
and you pay for it in cash and you
finish and get a master's in business
and that might open up some doors maybe
a little bit
but and you might end up your knowledge
base actually might cause you to make
more not really the degree
but um
beware of
anyone who tells you including telling
yourself that going back to school is
automatically worth it
at any cost for any degree because
unless it's permission to play that's
correct it's usually not worth it
it usually doesn't have an roi it's true
and if you overpay you ensure that it
doesn't have an roi yeah and one other
piece of advice for drew drew dave gave
you a really good target and i hear
heard the doubt in your voice because
you've got a mortgage now
2500 a month can be done with your skill
set as an engineer i would be besides
rice and beans uh in schooling you're
looking for extra work nights weekends
engineer type work where you can make
really good money per hour that would
allow you to reach that 40 50 bucks
right absolutely he could do that and
now all of a sudden what needs to be
true for him to pay 2500 a month to
knock this out in that time period it's
going to be extra work he has a skill
set that is in great demand he can find
a way to make extra money yeah
and
the faster you don't have any debt
the faster you start to build wealth
that's correct because your most
powerful wealth building tool
is not some kind of scheme or scam
where you try to figure out a way to
trick your way into it
um it's um your most power your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income
and it's simple when you don't have it
going out in payments and you put it in
the 401k
it and in your roth ira it causes you to
become wealthy it really is that
stinking simple it is there's only one
way to stack money dave you got to make
it and keep it and and we we overthink
this stuff it's pretty straightforward
yep
that answers that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
chuck is with us in indianapolis hi
chuck welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you doing great what's up well i
was calling in you know
i've been listening to your show for a
while and you know even your baby step
or whatnot
they was teaching at us in high school
some of you know some people didn't pay
attention you know what i mean
but those are the stuff that
you know i've been using
and
i wouldn't say i'm the best at using it
you know some people do what they after
they learn what they learn
but
i'm i own my own business and
you know it's going well but some you
know it has this ups and down and
sometimes man i'm like
should i just go give me a regular job
and just keep going you know
i mean i'm i'm to the point where i
don't know you know i don't know what to
do
you know without because you know
running your own business you have to
work all the hours you know
and
toughest balls you'll ever have
i'm sorry repeat that again i said
that's the toughest boss you'll ever
have working for yourself
that guy's a slave driver man he'll work
you in the ground
yep so
you know i'm like man sometimes i want
to be like normal people go out on a
regular day or you know i'm like well
you can't be normal
but then i'm like
yeah what kind of business is it chuck
a tow service
okay
is it just you and one truck what you
have a fleet what's going on
well i got multiple outfit but it's just
me though
and i you know i try to hire some people
but
people want to want so much they want so
much pain
but they can't do you know they can't
even back the truck up you know
i hear you what is the uh what's the
market rate what you think is the fair
rate for a tow truck driver i'm just
curious
that's what what the other people are
paying i can't you know
i know i know i don't care about other
people based on your business and your
revenue what's what's a rate that if you
could get somebody to take it today
you'd pay it happily
anywhere between 15 if that's if they're
good you know what i mean i hear you you
got to train them up okay you got to
train them up
but you know you know how many people i
train some people and then it's not even
training
you know this is not it's the continuous
learning because once i teach you each
job is not the same you know what i mean
sure
so what's the rate what's the right 15
to 20 an hour is that what you were
going to say
yes yes okay what'd you make last year
net profit
what for the business or me
well you i mean what'd you pay taxes on
last year
uh
120. okay
can you make that drive working for
somebody else
well
yeah i'ma have to work like a hebrew
slave for them
so would you rather work for you or for
them
yeah that's the thing working for me i
have to be the manager and this and you
know
the the thing with me is i can control
what i do you know right i can decide
hey like i was talking he was talking to
the other guy about the heat in the air
because most of my customers they happen
to see me when they call you know right
so
that's not the it's just more of the you
know so at this point i'm like man
sometimes i'm i'm more like i'm tired of
exchanging time for money you know
so if you could make 120 driving a truck
or some other kind of vehicle for
somebody else you didn't have to work
the crazy hours would you jump on it
would you even be calling us
yeah i know i can do that more myself
but it's you know
well you gotta look for it my point is
is it you you gotta decide right i
either wanna work for myself and then
i'm gonna have to try to hire somebody
and i know it's hard we hear this a lot
in entre leadership when we have our
leadership conferences it's really hard
i understand that to get good help but i
also believe there are people out there
who don't want to be in an office
who want to drive a truck or a tow truck
and they want to be somewhat autonomous
and they'll learn they'll get trained i
know you can find good people so you
have to double down and go all right i'm
either going to do the work to find good
people to train them up and pay them and
take some of my chief everything officer
off of me and begin to delegate it or
i'm going to say forget it i don't want
to deal with it i'm going to find a good
company where they value somebody like
me and i'll operate heavy equipment or
drive a truck make really good money and
leave it at the office or at the work
site and go home those are your two
choices yeah everything you said about
running your own business was negative
you don't you're tired of it you're done
mm-hmm
you know you didn't you didn't have any
fight left to fight us to say oh i
should keep because of this you never
not one thing did you say there's a
reason to keep it all the reasons we're
get reason to get out of it and there is
some reasons to keep it but you don't
have those anymore and so if i were you
i would close it up sell your truck
and go get you a good job and um not
have to worry about all this junk and
because you are you are officially done
just listening to you you don't want to
fool with it anymore
um you know unless you want to fight me
on that and you didn't have any fight
left when we were talking
then i i think that's the best route i i
think you're done
it's not to say one's better than the
other i'm just saying where you are
sam's with us in new york city hi sam
how are you
i am well dave and ken how about
yourselves better than we deserve what's
up
that's what i like to hear yeah so i'll
just give you a little bit of background
about myself so i'm 22 i i currently
have have no debt i'm moving to a new
city um because i'm a recent college
graduate starting a new job
and i need a car to commute in a
commerce car market i would have always
buy bought used but because car used car
prices are so high but oftentimes higher
than msrp i want to know if it makes
sense to consider the new car market
instead of the used car market
well that was true six months ago it's
not true today
used car used cars are back down again
and so they're not they're not all the
way back down to where they were there's
still some premiums on some of them but
um i mean if you start pulling up kelly
blue book uh you know trade-in values uh
even private sale values you'll find
used cars are still are again
substantially cheaper than new cars so a
good a good rule of thumb salmons unless
you have a million dollar net worth you
don't want to buy a new car they go down
in value too much how much money you got
to save for this car
i mean i've got saved up about 30 but my
salary is 100. good for you good for you
yeah i'd buy me a you know a a 20 000
you need an emergency fund left after
you buy it so i mean i'd buy a nice 20
000 good solid used car of some kind
that sounds fun if you're 22 and living
in new york and i'd pay cash for it and
i'd be done with it
and that's the only thing i would
consider doing here you don't want to
buy things that are going to go down in
value when you're 22 in your first job
you don't want to buy things that go
down in value ever unless you make so
much money and have so much net worth
that the amount you lose in value
doesn't matter
that's why we say when you have a
million dollar net worth if you want to
buy a new car that's fine because a new
car will lose 60 to 70 percent of its
value in the first four years that's the
average since we've been making new cars
it's like the world's worst investment
now they're fun and i love cars and i'm
a multi-millionaire i buy brand new cars
often i sometimes buy a used car
but um but i can afford the loss in
value it's it's it's not a relative
amount of money in in my in my situation
in your situation
it's a relative amount of money it's a
lot of money losing ten thousand dollars
on something right now in your life is a
lot
so i i wouldn't buy new not at all and
at 22 dave i thought you're very
generous i'd push him a little bit i'd
probably do 15 000. i mean 22 but hey
you got the money do exactly what dave
said there but you don't need a fancy
car just something nice and dependable
that's all you could trust a lot of car
for 20 grand
a lot of cars fabulous vehicles my
goodness i mean it's it's amazing what
you can get and certainly if you get a
brand that is very dependable doesn't
have a lot of mechanical issues i would
just stack that money if i were your age
i really would yeah
yeah and stay out of the car business
for a while i mean it's a it's a losing
business so and it is right now too
but yeah you're right six months ago uh
you know we had the supply chain issues
had messed up the car market like i
messed up the lumber market like it
messed up a lot of other markets
but nowadays uh some brands anyway are
cranking the factories back up and
they're dumping the new cars back on the
lots and that's bringing the used cars
back down
uh because new cars are starting to have
inventory again now some brands they
don't have any inventory still
they're still short but um
uh depends on what it is you're looking
at but but still i if i'm 22 that's what
i'm doing for sure that's the answer to
your question thank you for joining us
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
ah
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for joining us
we're so glad you're here luke is with
us in jackson mississippi starting off
this hour hi luke how are you good how
are y'all great how can ken coleman and
i help
so i'm currently in a job um i'm 22
years old and i've
been in this job for about two months um
and i've quickly found out that i'm not
really passionate about it why
um
well i'm i'm in the wine and liquor
industry i'm a sales rep
and it's just um
it's pretty difficult to watch people
come in in a store
who already have a pretty difficult life
and walk out with your products um
it's just a hard thing to deal with
um hard to see that happening so it's a
values disconnect
yes for sure
everyone that walks into a liquor store
and buys wine is not having a bad life
yeah i i know that but it's uh it's the
ones that are i'm in a pretty um
pretty poor area
and so it's it's the ones that are
coming off the streets like just just
pennies in their pockets coming in and
find the cheapest things on the shelf
just to get a just to get a drink why'd
you get into this you work in a liquor
store or you're a salesman for a
distributor
i'm a salesman for a distributor
so how are you dealing with the people
coming off the streets
well so i've got to go into the stores
and um
and and talk to the people to try and
talk to the the liquor store owners to
try and get them to get my products
um which a lot of them you know we have
some high-end products but a lot of them
are
to target those those
cheaper customers that are just trying
to get a quick drink
okay
i'm just curious i understand all the
understanding it's very personal for you
what i'm curious about is how how did
you make this decision to get into this
two months ago well
well i i uh
i wanted to originally get into medical
device sales
which is a very it's a difficult field
to get into without sales experience
and so my my original intention was to
just try and get my foot in the door for
the first couple years
um and just get some sales experience
under my belt so that i could then move
into that other um that other field
but it's just
right now it's it's getting pretty
difficult to no i get it going because
it's just it's just a moral thing sure i
get it but you took this opportunity
just because it was i need some
experience i got to sell something and
this presented itself and you jumped
into it that's what i'm understanding
exactly all right so here's the deal
stop overthinking this you're going to
stay in this role and you're going to
have to suck it up a little bit and
you're not doing anything morally wrong
i understand your feelings i don't want
in any way to discount what you're
feeling convictions all that but the
fact is you're not doing anything wrong
and so sit still and keep doing the job
until you find another sales job to
replace it with that's the advice and i
appreciate what you're trying to do get
some sales experience somewhere else but
now you've got to learn from this and go
wait a second i'm not just going to take
any sales job i need to make sure that
i'm gonna sell a service or product
that i'm okay with and you can't
overthink this you know because again
there's nothing wrong with with
distributing alcohol or selling alcohol
but in your situation this is very very
personal so i wouldn't overthink this
let's make the move how about you how
much are you making
uh 45 000. okay so find another sales
job making 45 to 60 000
selling something you're proud of and
then change that's what cancer that's
right but then get in proximity if you
can if you could get selling something
that's near or around that medical field
i would try to look for that first
do you understand what i'm saying
because it's connections at this point
not just experience but connections
okay
and and make sure that as you're doing
that that you're taking on something you
can be proud of
everyone in sales needs to remember it's
very difficult to be a great sales
person selling something you don't
believe in yes
yeah and that's that's the thing that
i've been i've been struggling with
because yeah i've got alcoholism on both
sides of my family um from both my
parents sides
um
so it's that that's been the hardest
part is just not really um
care i don't really believe in the
products that i'm yeah that i'm selling
and that's been the hardest part
if an opportunity similar to this
presents itself
don't take it for sure there's something
else because you had red flags before
you took this
yeah you're only two months in so i know
you did
and and now it's manifested and it's
actually worse than you thought it was
going to be
in terms of convicting you
and you know your your morals are saying
ding ding ding ding ding the alarms are
going off get out of here so yeah go
find something else as soon as you can
and then quit but don't just quit every
time you have a
uh adversity uh a situation you know so
again i don't want you there six years
from now i don't want you there six
months from now you ought to be able to
find a sales job doing that
so uh doing something that you actually
believe in
you know ken here over the years we've
developed we develop products books or
software or apps or
classes or whatever
and one of the biggest challenges is to
make sure that
um
that we're all proud of
what it is we're putting out the instant
we're not proud of it
we can't ask anybody including me
to suggest it to someone sells to
someone
that's what sales is it's suggesting you
do something right
and uh you can't suggest
you know buying a car
if you hate
uh that brand and you think that brand's
a piece of crap
and then you're going to go to work for
that dealer you know
uh and so yeah that's that's going to be
a problem yeah so don't uh don't take a
position where you're not proud of
where you work
so true and specifically in sales
because sales you know period people
but it's very difficult very difficult
in sales because you're an evangelist
right that's your role and people can
fake it and there's a lot of fakes out
there that hit their sales numbers but
if you are a person of conviction and
you've got a true ethical code to you it
will wear you down if you can't get
excited to the point of evangelizing
on behalf of the product or the service
that you're selling it's absolutely it
will [ __ ] you it just will yeah it's
very difficult because people can
your
body language changes
that's right changes your facial
expressions change all your non-verbals
are are just not there that's correct
you know when you're doing that and so
um
i mean if you're selling a uh in his
case a
a line of whiskey that is uh
you know the bottom of the barrel no pun
intended
um and um
and it's designed to take advantage of
the homeless
then you're not gonna you're gonna be
fired up about that yeah you know the
drunk homeless guy right so you're not
gonna be jump you're not nobody's gonna
be excited about that
um now you know but uh so you just got
to find a way to do the thing you do
that is not violation of your morals or
find something period that isn't but
don't be just
after two months jumping out without
having something to jump to that well
that's right so the first thing i said
was hey you're going to stay put and you
made this decision so you're going to be
an adult about this until we find
something to replace that income you
don't just say i don't like it i can't
do it anymore and he wasn't saying that
but got to be careful you know well i
mean there's a that's honorable work you
know for a lot of people yeah for him
it's not a good fit exactly
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
thank you for joining us we're glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
halfway through august can you believe
it next week every store will probably
have a freaking christmas sale
that's true if fall means planning to go
broke until tax season make it this year
uh
make this year the one you say no i'm
not gonna do that enough is enough
the ramsay ten dollar sale is back for a
very limited time if you're ready to say
enough we're here to help you and our
team isn't stopping there we're gonna
help you solve your money worries by
offering free financial coaching with
any purchase you can talk to a ramsey
preferred coach about your specific
money question
and are you ready to say i've had it and
then you can learn to say i've got this
uh we know 10 bucks can't get you much
these days but at ramsey you can any one
of our best-selling books is on sale for
ten dollars or virtually all of them
anyway check them out at
ramseysolutions.com
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
now use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from kendall in california i just
graduated high school and i'm wondering
if it's right for me to go to college
this year my school starts in two weeks
and i have a full ride i would be
studying economics in hopes of going
into investment banking this past year i
discovered i have a knack for drop
shipping and i'm making sixty seven
hundred dollars a month in profit i'm
seriously considering withdrawing from
college but don't know if that's the
right move
well that's loaded
and i don't have the opportunity to go
back and forth there but i'm always
going to look at the long term so the
long term dream
if you do want to go into investment
banking
certainly the economics degree is going
to help i think it's a good degree to
have you've got a full ride that's a
tremendous opportunity a lot of people
don't get i'd be talking with mom and
dad about the long term and this 6 700 a
month it's probably going to grow in
profit that to me would be i'd be saving
up for big life expenses the house and
investing long term uh so i would not
drop out of this path
of college towards uh investment banking
just because you're making so much money
with the drop shipping side hustle i
think it's a great side hustle i think
you'll learn a lot from that but this is
a big picture decision and you need to
surround yourself with wise counsel and
make the right decision based on the
long term
i don't know enough more in that
question dave to i'd love to talk to
that young man in person uh for the long
term just graduated from high school
sixty seven hundred dollars you feel
like you're rich exactly you're not rich
yeah 6700
enrich uh you're not rich you need to go
get that economics degree and become an
investment banker
then you can get rich but um and in the
meantime while you're going and getting
the degree go ahead and work the drop
ship yeah that's fantastic you know i
don't care if you make ten thousand
dollars a month out of your dorm room
doesn't make me mad
that's good hustle it's a great hustle
for a young man straight out of high
school but don't confuse the short term
ken's exactly right with the long term
play just because you feel rich
um i mean you know i won ten thousand
dollars on the lottery i don't have to
work yeah you gotta work that's right
you're not rich yeah and so that you
still gotta work yeah you're not done
and um that that's the thing so
yeah go for the long play where it's
gonna take you where you wanna be when
you're 40. what's going to make you
what's going to the
you know the 40 year old version of you
is not wanting to kick the 18 year old
version of you's butt for doing
something stupid
think about it when you think about that
guy who's that guy
and where is he going to be happy which
one's he going to be happy he did i i so
i think you do both
go to school and keep running the drop
ship
driving you're not carrying inventory
you're just you're just com you're
manipulating the
uh the wholesaler with a bite with a
retail buyer and you know pulling the
plug out of the middle
and that's all you're doing so it's uh
if you've got something working that
well
i think you can still pull that off
hey thanks for the thanks for the email
in we appreciate it emily's with us in
casper wyoming hi emily welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave and ken it's a pleasure to speak
with you
you too how can we help
well i'm calling for strategy for
starting to withdraw from our 529 plans
we're in baby step 7 and our oldest is
starting college and then we also have a
sophomore in high school that could be
attending college in three more years
the current value is 37 000 but this
past december it was at 50 000.
uh we are prepared to cash flow about
half of the expenses but i'm wondering
about strategies for
um we have two kids one colleges
would would half be one kid
no half monthly each year so
for her total expenses
we're prepared to
if we need to we can cash for half of it
and withdraw from the 529 for the other
half
just to leave some in the fund so that
we can
i would leave it all in the fine and
cash flow the whole thing what are you
what are you spending on school
um it'll be about fifteen thousand a
year
what do you all make
uh 120
and you don't have a payment in the
world your baby steps seven
correct
okay
well you can cash flow 15 000 a year
then
yes we could yeah okay yeah i i would
leave the 37 for the second kid
and let it grow tax-free
and then just pay this one
okay pay for this one
yeah i mean it doesn't matter but um
you know because here's the thing that
the growth in the 529 is 100 tax-free
the more of that you get tax-free that
you did not do anything for except
parking the money
is good and so leaving it alone as long
as possible to get that as much tax-free
growth as possible is free money
okay is that logical
it is yeah it's funny i didn't think
about that i just thought we would start
with drawing
uh do we still keep contributing or we
just stop contributions and then just i
wouldn't contribute beyond what you
think you're gonna need for kid too if
you're gonna cash flow kid one
okay but i would contribute up to kid
two's limit i mean if you're doing
fifteen thousand a year for four years
that's 60 000 you got 39 000 now once
that thing looks like it's going to be
at 60 by the time kid 2 gets there i'd
stop adding
yeah as of december we were almost there
yeah so he could come back to that
pretty easily so i don't know i don't
think i'd put anything else in it
i think a cash flow kid won and if uh it
doesn't ever come back then you're gonna
cash flow part of kid too and
empty the thing out on kid too but i
suspect it's going to come back
yeah and then i guess we could also use
it as an emergency fund for education
that if we did have a month where we had
an emergency we wouldn't have to dip
into our emergency fund to get into our
529 if needed yeah if you're getting a
cash pinch because of the timing of when
a tuition payment's due or something you
can reach over there and grab it and of
course the other thing is if the kids go
get scholarships of any kind you can
withdraw up to the amount of the
scholarship from the 529 with no taxes
at all
okay so if they get a two thousand
dollar scholarship pluck two thousand
bucks out of there and just
put it in something else and and just
even if you're gonna turn around and use
it right then but it's completely
tax-free
um you don't have to do anything there's
no no obligation that it be spent on
uh education at that point uh but that's
not your problem you're not you haven't
got too much in there you got too little
in there so yeah very cool very good i'm
glad i think through that with you
that's very interesting
so
sounds like they got an affordable
school it's a good school yeah goodbye
at 15 000 a year for
higher ed four years 60 grand yep that's
that's a play it is and i you know i
it's going to be interesting to see what
shakes out over the next five to seven
years
for parents that are listening with
younger kids
the the tuition game i think is gonna
change i think it's gotten overheated
just like a lot of things in our economy
and i don't have any predictions here
i'm just saying i think it's going to be
very interesting to see how the world of
college tuition and higher education
shifts over the next five to seven years
uh i predict higher ed is not going to
get the memo
soon enough
to keep some of them from really taking
it on the chin yep they sit in their own
little ivory tower no pun intended
that's right
and
too many of them in that world have not
woke up and smelled the coffee yet
tuition rates cannot continue to rise
it's not well and people are no longer
willing to pay
you you want to charge me the same and
let me sit at home because of your
masking policy on covid and i don't
think so that's called online classes
they're cheaper
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today thank you for joining us america
we're so glad you are with us
bill and sherry are with us there in
fort myers florida says on my screen you
guys are debt-free congratulations
yes thank you way to go how much did you
pay off
we paid off 438
806
and 32 cents wow how long did that take
well it took 13 years okay i wanted to
be on the show to let others hear a
perseverance story i hear you good for
you and your range of income during that
time
uh we started out at zero and then we
quickly grew that to about 80 and we're
currently sitting at about 225. cool
what do y'all do for a living
well i'm an elementary school teacher
and i work for siemens i'm an
electrical sales engineer for them very
cool what's the house worth i take it
you paid off your house
oh yes absolutely way to go weirdos i
love it
y'all are excellent how old are you
we're 58 and uh what's this house worth
well it wasn't just the house uh we have
a strange story dave we we got started
in real estate a little bit like you
uh back when we were 28 that was 30
years ago but we had subscribed to this
mail order real estate course called
carlton sheets oh yeah no money down guy
remember him i remember carlton yeah
don't ever do that
anyway he was like buy this one and then
borrow from it and buy the next one so
we had 10 apartments
uh we paid off a motor home 10
apartments and in our home our home in
florida that we live in now so you own
all of it free and clear
free and clear absolutely what's it all
worth
oh i guess all the assets together would
probably be
in the area of 2 million way to go guys
i love it
that's excellent baby steps millionaires
well done
well done good stuff man i'm so proud of
y'all
good good work
so what puts you on this whole ramsey
way of doing things
well believe it or not in uh back in 08
we had one of those life moments this is
why you want to always have an emergency
fund we didn't have one we had all these
apartments we're paying on these
apartments and if there's a vacancy it's
a real problem yeah but i i was doing
great in my career i i was having a
great sales you know sales year my wife
was teaching she goes you know our son's
going into high school i'd like to be
home so i can be involved in that i said
do it and i said i'm having a great year
well you know what happened six weeks
later i was laid off oh my god so we
went all the way to zero and uh one of
sherry's teacher friends melissa weigel
gave us your book
and i read in one night one sitting and
i said geez i wish i'd learned this in
high school i said we're doing this and
we just took off from there
wow
so sherry you didn't have to be talked
into it at all
oh no no i was like oh i i am the
thrifty
shopper okay you know i like consignment
shops and so i was all on board to begin
with i wanted to get out of debt and
and start a free life yeah i love it
good for you guys
well done well done thank you what do
you tell people the key to persevering
for 13 years is
well you know certainly you got to get
that budget out and talk about it once a
month even if it's painful
but you got to review it you got to be
in sync with your spouse
my wife and i still have the 50 rule i'm
hoping that'll go up here soon
we don't let either the person spend 50
without checking so that seems a really
helps
i feel like we got to dive in on that
with sharia how do you feel about
raising the 50 limit he brought it up
people want to know
well listen i'm still very conservative
i like to to have a nest egg and know
what's there for our future and not to
to touch it and you know i kind of had
to keep him on a budget but um he's
doing really good i have to say that um
we're both kind of on the same page and
that's so important sure you got two
million dollars
i know it needs to be 100 it needs to be
a hundred dollar rule okay yeah
come on sherry okay maybe we'll go up to
a hundred dollars there we go
wow
hey bill you owe dave and i on that one
by the way share you answer that one
like a politician on a sunday morning
show
oh you guys are fun very well done very
well done okay so for
13 years you've persevered from that
zeroed both of you lose
her quitting you losing the job we go to
zero scares the crud out of us for 13
years you've leaned into this
now when you look back was it worth it
oh my gosh the feeling is absolutely
incredible god is so good and and we are
just very blessed absolutely we worked
hard but i wouldn't have changed it at
all
yeah way to go well i got to tell you
we're proud of you you're pretty amazing
so couple million dollars worth of real
estate there and and uh and net worth in
excess of that and uh a good household
income and you know you're not even 60.
so you got lots of time to enjoy this
lots of good stuff ahead very very well
done
so um
if you had it to do over again what
would you do different anything
oh i think we would have started off
when we were like
25 when we got married
yeah and maybe we wouldn't have had such
a huge wedding
and maybe you wouldn't have bought
nothing down apartments
yeah maybe you wouldn't about nothing
down apartments
all right that's right yeah okay
wow good for you guys good stuff good
stuff hey we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you you are one and uh
that's very very cool
a one-year membership to financial peace
university for your use or you can give
it to someone who runs into your story
and is inspired and you want to help
them same thing with the total money
makeover book
uh eight million people have now read
that book well i mean people bought the
book we think most of them read it so um
there's that
so hey guys way to go very very proud of
you excellent excellent job bill and
sherry fort myers florida 439 000
housing apartments and everything in 13
years making 0 to 80 to 225
count it down baby steps millionaires
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two
one
thank you jesus
[Applause]
that is how that is done
well done you two
very very well done
man
so there is a principle
here of um
diligence
the bible says the diligent
prosper
diligence is
excellence in the ordinary
over time
doing it every day
well
with
and they prosper
as opposed to what are they calling the
thing on tick tock quitting while you're
quiet quitting yeah quiet quitting like
being at work and not working yeah is
that the idea the idea is i'm not going
to do any more than it's expected of me
i'm just going to do the bare minimum go
home and i'm not going to get any i
would agree with that if you signed up
for a 40-hour work week and they're
trying to work you 80. oh sure you know
and you're like okay i'm going home you
you know at five because we go home at
ramsey i mean we close this place down
and yeah we go to home to our families
at night but we work hard while we're
here if anybody
quiet quitting quite quietly quit
while they're here during the day i'll
quiet fire them yeah it'll be very quiet
that would be quiet i love that that
would that would like you're not working
while you're at work that's called lack
of diligence well yeah lack of character
kind of like stealing yeah but i don't
can't tell some of the stuff seems to
talk about that like don't don't work
while you're at work like some kind of
like i'm going to strike there together
i'm a millennial or whatever i am or i'm
a whatever some kind of snowflake and i
don't want to work and you're going to
pay me anyway well i'll just fire your
little butt yeah i can fix that um
but you know but if you just are if
you're instead saying oh i'm going to do
the work that that we agreed i was going
to do and i'm not going to work 80 hours
a week then that's fine because i didn't
ask somebody to work 80 hours a week
here we don't do that
now occasionally we have to because
something's messed up we got to get you
know we got to get something done but
it's a short-term thing because it's a
small business we have to get our work
done but
this idea that i'm gonna quietly
not work
which a lot of people were doing that
anyway they're just sitting on their
facebook account
while they're at work
and unless you work in social media
that's not working
well listen
and that's diligence these guys on the
other side of this call we just took was
diligence baby steps millionaires versus
average yeah
where do you want to be
average mediocre
they'll quietly quit
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today romans 15 13 may the
god of hope fill you with all joy and
peace and believing
so that by the power of the holy spirit
you may abound in hope
bobby knight said nothing great was ever
achieved without enthusiasm
oh that's a truth
wow good stuff ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's the
host of the ken coleman show now heard
on over 75 radio stations and has a
podcast and a youtube show
audience increasing every single month
to that show lots of you tuning in to
learn about and talk about how to find
career work that matters
work that gives you a sense of joy a
sense of traction and
hey also check out his number one
best-selling books including the
proximity principle and paycheck to
purpose the big dog book it's uh helping
a lot of people walk through the seven
step process to finding work
and doing work
and giving it away that they love
again ken coleman my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five shade is with us in
wisconsin hi shade how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i am
28 years old i am about to have my
second child up in april yay
i am trying to go back to school to find
a better paying job i have a couple
options i'm trying to go for an
operating engineer
um
one of the options is staying here where
i am and just going to the tech school
and get my cdl
uh the other option would be going down
to sun prairie for a school that would
cost roughly around ten thousand a
little bit more than ten thousand
dollars
okay there's financial aid involved in
that
um and then the third option
is being a
apprentice
but i do believe that would be traveling
okay
uh if the if the uh apprenticeship
opportunity did not involve travel how
open to that would you be
uh seeing that it's still paid i'd be
very open yeah that's what i heard in
your voice i'd get absolute clarity on
that was that just the way you said it
with your voice or you're not quite sure
you've heard something but you're not
quite sure how much travel if any is
involved
i'm not sure i'd find out let me tell
you why uh because of a how you reacted
that's the best option for you and your
life but i also love
the opportunity for the apprenticeship
this is doing two things for you
experience and connections and you're
getting paid for it so i really like
that option do you have any cash set
aside for the other two options
i do not i've been i just got a brand
new job starting at like 17 an hour
so that's going for me but nothing so
far
what uh besides your heart hurting would
and being away from what i mean by that
as you're being away from your wife and
one child and the other one on the way
well besides that uh makes the
apprenticeship with travel uh not so
desirable for you anything else besides
that
um
just
not knowing you know i do have a car
that i'm still paying on so not knowing
what
just
what it all involves you know not
yeah so here's the deal i want you as
soon as this phone call is over at least
make a phone call and email
get some information on this because if
this apprenticeship pays you 17 an hour
or more and it's going to involve some
travel away from the wife and the little
ones and they're so little they'll never
know
i'm just going to tell you of the three
options that i've heard it's the best
option on the table i understand there's
some sacrifice involved but that's part
of the journey you're going to sacrifice
one way or the other and you don't have
the money to take on the schooling now
anyway and we don't want you to go into
debt for it so you're you're going to
sacrifice time by saving you have to
work harder stack up the money to pay
for this path versus get paid to be
trained and so i i really would look
intensely into
what would it take to win uh in that
apprenticeship
i would okay that's what i would do
yeah that's exactly what i would do
um
and uh what are you making now
i just i don't know the total but i know
it's like
seven 17 17 you're making 17 now 29 yeah
no i'm making
14 now okay oh okay i thought so what is
it you're signing up that what is it you
want to become an opera or what
operating engineer
so pretty much the guys that drive the
big old like construction equipment
oh okay
all right
all right
yeah i'm gonna do that the cheapest
possible way in the fastest possible way
just to get trained to operate the
equipment whatever that is
um
and um
that's some that's some good money once
you're certified right
yes
like what kind of money once you're
certified
uh i could be making i do believe like
36 an hour yeah or more yeah okay yeah
all right
and uh well that that's exactly what um
that's exactly what you do yeah you get
the fastest
least expensive way with the least
trouble
and so uh like my um
when we when i graduated from college my
wife lacked uh
four or five classes finishing her
degree and we moved away from knoxville
where we were in school to nashville in
those days the uh college in the area
mtsu didn't match up with
it was a one with semester one was
quarters and it was going to end up
taking a year and a half for her to
finish what was otherwise three or four
classes and we discovered she could take
the three or four classes if she went
back to knoxville for six weeks
and we had just had our first child and
so she drove to knoxville every weekend
without my brand new daughter
for six weeks
and she cried and i cried more every
time she left the driveway for six
weekends
and went to class six weeks put the kid
in daycare for six weeks to finish the
degree and drove back it was the longest
most horrible six weeks ever
but in the scope of my life
it really didn't amount to squat
okay it was worth it you know we
sacrificed for her to finish the degree
um and it did not it was not a degree
that she needed to finish uh to be able
to do the career
that she wanted to uh to do
and um you know but it was the best way
so i tell you what you hang on for a
second here i'm getting a call in
brian's in owensboro looks like he's got
the better advice
than ken or me so brian it says on my
screen you're an operating engineer and
you've got advice for shade
i am an operating engineer at a local
181 here in jones and henderson kentucky
i live in owensboro but
i have been an operating engineer for 27
years and my best advice to you young
man is to take the apprenticeship
program and the operators union ken
coleman there it is ladies and gentlemen
good i have been i have been debt free
since i was 18 years old wow what are
you making an hour
i make right now uh different contracts
are different i just got off a job
making 34.80 an hour if i work in
southern indiana it's 37.40 an hour
and i usually average between
right now between 90 and 130 000 a year
depending on because i also run
cranktastic
wow good for you well there's advice
shade from a guy who really does it you
can't beat that no come in i love that
come in and give us you know there's a
guy in the field says do it and uh so
your instinct was correct ken well only
because the apprenticeship is is really
what the american economy was built on
number one and it's just simply i get
paid to actually get experience and
that's the best of both worlds you know
uh because what he's going to learn in
that apprenticeship so if you want to
sell real estate go to work for a high
producing real estate sales person as
and get their coffee yeah that's exactly
right and learn how to do it create your
own apprenticeship is what you're
suggesting exactly uh yeah i think it's
the it was the right route based on
those other two options because he's
going to spend money to sit in a
classroom or he's going to get paid to
actually get in the truck
yeah
i mean you know what i mean like if you
just think about it the the old days
you know you lived above the the shop
for the guy you worked with you know you
know the old blacksmith or whatever that
kind of a thing yeah that's a different
deal but but this is a high tech here i
mean oh yeah but the apprenticeship is a
real opportunity in today's world it
really is it's coming back trucks in
them yeah major dozers or whatever
they're good stuff
very interesting very interesting good
stuff
well that puts this hour in the books
our thanks to james to andrew zack ben
and austin in the booth ken coleman good
hour i am dave ramsey your host we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there is ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you